in order to forge a lasting bond
with the marines people i will reopen
the fighting bits
marine was the slaver city that
specialized in producing these
fighting slaves yongkai and osterport
had had fighting pits too
not like in marine marine was where the
big ones were
they're all over the city small ones for
neighborhood bouts
then the gigantic does not pit where
hundreds of thousands can gather watch
men fight each other danny closes movie
when she takes the city
but that just makes her more unpopular
not only has she conquered the city and
put a lot of their
leaders to death but she's outlawed
their favorite sport
that is greatness that is a vital part
of the great city of miriam
which existed long before uri and will
remain standing long after we have
returned to the dirt
one of the things that danny is
wrestling with is how do i make the
people
accept my rule i did not take up
residence in this pyramid so i could
watch the city below decline into chaos
she thinks it's barbaric and
ugly and repulsive but does she have the
right to outline
those men think they're dying for a good
reason
so your reasons are true and there's a
false they don't know their own minds
but you do
people love blood when it's not their
own
but tavern brawls are boring and wars
never have good seating
thus the famed fighting pits of marine
opened shortly after the city's own
founding
and i heard that originally the combats
were a blood sacrifice to the gods of
geese
the empire that founded marine some
still believe they are
but the ghiscari empire died a long time
ago and their gods went with them
yet the pits remained open filling the
city's purse with gold from the ends of
the earth
i suppose the fighting pits are a blood
sacrifice after all
only the gods changed in the pits
slaves fought each other to the death
for fame and glory
and gold for their masters a lot of gold
enough for the masters to invest in
rigorous training
slaves were taught to fight like
dothraki screamers
bearded priests of norway's ironborn
rivers
westerosi knights cohortic hunters
and leasing pirates whatever would
excite a crowd
after all everyone wants to know who is
the best
and of course who isn't for the crowds
don't come only to see men fight well
i've seen the masters release tigers
lions and other exotic beasts into the
arena
to chase less costly slaves
barely trained if at all a [ __ ] once
told me of an amusement
in one of the less prestigious pits one
boy was rolled in honey
one in blood and one in rotting fish
and then a bear was unleashed and the
crowd waged on which
boy the bear would eat first i never
heard who won
then again it was obvious the masters
did such stories worry me of course not
i could fight and for a good fighter
life was luxurious
thousands of people chanted his name
when he stepped into the pits
he would eat the choicest meats drink
the finest wines
and sleep on exotic furs often not alone
women would fling themselves at him or
sneak into his chambers to wait for him
after a fight
foreign princesses priestesses and even
the wives and wayward daughters of
masters
may never had to fear punishment for a
great fighter
could be worth three hundred thousand
owners
another wife was always cheaper
and when this renowned fighter finally
fell for all fighters will
in time his name would be inscribed unto
the gates of fate among the other
valiant dead
i remember once trying to count the
names
but the gates opened before i finished
and another fight began